Mizkif is seen as a middling creator. Oh god, a middling creator.
He he he a What the [__] Uh if you if you're squeamish,
don't look, okay? But this is what happened to me, okay? This
is my story. This is what happened to me. Hey yo, hey yo, are
you good, dog? She literally said she has notes. She's got detailed
notes. She shows the paper with the where the notes are written.
She's clearly reading the notes when she said she was assaulted.
>> Emiru responds to Mizkif's defamation
Okay? So, guys, if you're familiar, Mizkif launched a defamation
lawsuit against Emiru and Asmongold. Emiru is now responding.
This is Emiru's response. Henry's going to go over for us, okay?
I've now been covering the Mizkif defamation lawsuit he filed
against his ex-girlfriend Emiru. We recently covered his amended
complaint, and I had some things to say about most of them kind
of being baseless. But that's just my opinion. You can actually
scroll through and read it for yourself to figure out what you
find is baseless and what you find is credible. However, I did
say that he had a case when she said she was SA'd. But according
to her most recent legal filing that was filed March 3rd, 2026,
which is yesterday at this time of this recording, uh she sees
it differently or her lawyer sees it differently. So, without
further ado, let's get into it. And one thing I want to bring
to your attention before we get into it, Emiru's statements contain
her protected emotional
truth.
Dude, Henry is not letting this [__] off the hook.
Henry not letting this [__] off the hook, okay? Dude,
this is precisely what I said happened, by the way, to everybody.
And people are like, "No, you're wrong. No, you're wrong. No,
you're wrong." I'm like, "Listen, that's how she felt at the
time. It's understandable she could feel that way. It doesn't
mean that something was done super incorrectly on Mizkif's part.
It's it's probably how she felt at the
And it turns out her testimony will be that's how I felt at the
time.
Okay? Her emotional truth. >> section for a lot of people.
But we have to get there, okay? Also, she do not want this ninja
to make any
more amended complaints.
But she leaves room for it just in case he does. So, without
further ado,
let's get into it. She's like all these legal cases to support
her claims, statutes, and other authorities. Let's get into it.
Defendant Emiru hereby moves to dismiss the first amended complaint
filed by Mizkif and Mizkif Enterprises and together with Miss
Rindino pursuant to Federal Rule Procedure Civil Procedure 12b,
failure to state a claim. Similar to the same thing as we go.
In alternative, Emiru moves for a more definitive statement pursuant
to the rule of Civil Procedure 12e. All right, so she wants it
out. For clarity, Emiru strenuously denies the claims alleged
in the first amended complaint as is confident that she will
The weird thing about this is like
how do I put this?
Is this not also like almost as if she's
Cuz I think she's going to argue that she's talking about how
she felt. But she does not make that clear on the stream herself.
In fact, I believe her stream opens with like trigger warning
for
That's not really a feel statement. Emiru Mizkif. Let's see if
I can find her like um her original statement
Yeah, trigger warning Mizkif. Okay, it says trigger warning Mizkif.
Does she not Is she not like literally confessing
that she understands she wasn't telling the truth? Like listen,
this is what she said. >> Today, I'm finally going to be
opening up about
the psychological and domestic abuse, stalking, and harassment,
assault, and threats of blackmail that Mizkif has done towards
me. Transcript Transcript says Mizkif,
like it's a woman. Mizkif.
Okay, well, she might be reading a script. It doesn't matter
from her statement. But to me, aren't you sort of yourself a
little bit when you say when you go and you say this outright?
Like you are making that accusation. It is sort of defama- It
It seems to be defamation per se, and then you go and you admit
in the filing that it's not that. You say, "Well, that's just
how I felt." If that's what she really says,
but like that would make some acknowledgement that it's like
not necessarily true.
Like I don't understand how a lawyer filed that. It feels like
it muddies the water massively.
But maybe not. We'll keep listening. Mizkif's claims on its merits.
However, for the purposes of this motion, Emiru merely moves
for a dismissal of the first amended complaint or an alternative,
a more definitive statement on the grounds of its legal inadequacy.
She looks forward to proving the lack of factual merit in the
first amended complaint, if necessary, should the case progress
past the pleading stage.
Now, do I think it's going to get
It's going to be tough, man.
Introduction and factual background.
The first amended complaint is a temper tantrum disguised as
legal filing. God damn, she She already called him just found
it. He has a temper tantrum. Mizkif's original complaint contained
only a single two-sentence quote describing the supposedly defamatory
statements by Emiru and Asmongold.
Asmongold rightfully filed a motion to It's possible that his
It's possible
Mizkif might have done a really poor job of arguing this in his
original complaint. Cuz this is what you have to say, right?
It's like, "Okay, I'm opening up today about these stories."
And she says a story about assault. She says, "I'm going to talk
about assault." And there's really only one thing in the stream
that could possibly be assault, and it's all about Mizkif anyway,
So, like, it's not really ambiguous. I wonder what sentences
are included. >> dismissed the deficient complaint and
Mizkif quickly amended the feat and withdrew the complaint. Now,
this is, you know, kind of semantics. His original complaint
wasn't withdrew, it was amended. So, it no longer is what the
response is. So, you can, you know, you can say it was withdrew,
but this typically happens. The first amended complaint contains
more words than original complaint, but no more substance. Man,
her lawyer is just cooking out the gate. Mizkif is a content
creator, meaning that his primary occupation is the creation
of a live stream or streaming content posted on various online
platforms, including but not limited to Twitch, YouTube, and
Kick.
As alleged in the first amended complaint, Mizkif earns
income by gaining subscribers who pay monthly to support his
live stream content and through advertising within the next to
his live streams. In other words, the more eyeballs on his streams,
the more money Mizkif makes. I mean, that's just the truth. >> That's
a truthful statement. And then I Okay. This next part is [__]
up, okay? This next part is actually really [__]
up. I'm not going to lie to you, okay?
>> Get ready. This attention economy of content creators,
Mizkif is seen as a middling creator. Oh god, a middling creator.
He He He a middling What the [__]
there's a lawyer writing it, so maybe you could argue it's the
lawyer saying these things.
Maybe but Jesus, man. Jesus Christ. >> the top of this
no more. He is not as popular as as I Maru, nor is he particularly
well liked in the community of content creators. >> That's
a truthful statement. His brand has been volatile for many years
due to self-inflicted
public controversies, in which he puts himself against other
content creators. And right now, that's exactly what he's doing.
He's literally going at any and everybody on YouTube or Twitch
or or any platform to kind of stay relevant. Amouranth
any content?
Maybe. Maybe that's Maybe that's kind of true. He's going after
a lot of people.
I feel like he's just I I felt like he was unleashed. He felt
like unburdened.
Okay, he was just going after anyone. In comparison H- Henry
simping?
Oh no, there's no good comment I can make. I like Henry. I I
like Henry.
Henry's not simping, OKAY? OH NO. NO! WAIT, what did What did
he just say? >> any platform to kind of stay relevant.
Amouranth in comparison is at the top of her field. Amouranth
is best known for live streaming videos on Twitch where she plays
video games and posts cosplay.
Bro, you got a
You got a viewership bog him in the lawsuit?
It wasn't enough to do it during the relationship and have him
like cause like nervous [__] breakdowns for the guy?
You got to do it in the [__] lawsuit?
Really? like content and speaks directly to her viewers. She
is one of the most popular female streamers on Twitch with in
millions with millions of followers across multiple platforms.
She was recently profiled in Forbes for their 30 under 30 list
as the head of their games category which described her as the
most watched female streamer on Twitch with an expanding media
empire. Yeah, she
She cooking. You can't You can't deny that. Is she cooking? Unfortunately
for Amouranth, she entered into a romantic relationship with
Mizkif in 2022.
The
>> Dude, it's brutal. What the [__]
Uh I I thought they were going to get married. Unfortunately
for her
she entered into a romantic relationship with Mizkif. Jesus.
>> disastrous and in January 2025,
Amouranth ended the relationship and ceased all communication
with Mizkif. God damn. And I'm off. Cut him off. So, remember,
ended in January. Now, fast forward. In early October 2025, Amaru
was assaulted by a member of the public at TwitchCon, an annual
conference held by Twitch. The assault was captured Uh objection,
relevance. Uh objection. Oh.
Oh,
you. Yeah. You, Mr. Lawyer. Okay. Nah.
Nah, that scummy
Oh, you see what he's going to try to do, right? Well, actually,
the reason she would she the reason she was going to talk about
assault was cuz like she's talking about her TwitchCon assault,
No, she wasn't. No, she wasn't. No, she
I don't know if Mizkif is watching, but uh well, I don't know
if Mizkif would be watching. But literally in her YouTube video,
Mizkif is the section name. And under the Mizkif section is where
we get everything about Today, I'm going to finally be opening
up about psychological abuse stalking and harassment and assault
and threats of blackmail that Mizkif has done towards me and
some of these issues which are still ongoing.
So, when you say that like when you're going to talk about the
October No, that was not what you were talking about. Oh, that's
slimy. video by a fan and caused a global media firestorm, particularly
due to the questions pertaining to Twitch's handling of the situation.
That's a truthful statement. Separately,
Amaru had been receiving concerning information from multiple
sources. Now, here's the thing, right? I'm not sure this has
anything to do with Mizkif other than Amaru's sympathy. You know,
and I'm not defending Miz, but what does this have to do with
what she
Okay, so, right then there, separately, Amaru had been receiving
concerning information from multiple sources regarding Mizkif's
inappropriate and highly concerning behavior. Mizkif was reportedly
harassing her through private messages, making inappropriate
comments to friends and employees, attempting to interact with
with at parties despite her attempts to avoid him, and discussing
her in his live streams and videos because of her decision to
cut off their romantic relationship. His behavior Um, fact check,
I believe Mizkif cut the relationship off.
Okay. I'm going to debunk that right now. Actually, I don't have
the facts to debunk it, but I will later cuz they are better
They're going to better slot in later, okay? But let's just say
I'm going to let you know preemptively that that is debunked,
okay? Debunked. Mizkif at I Well,
I think we saw this actually when they talked about it. I'm pretty
sure this wasn't even really contested that Mizkif ended the
relationship.
behavior was escalating and in Now, I would say Mizkif probably
ended it, but it seems like he was trying to talk afterwards.
Now, was he trying to rekindle it? I don't know.
Mizkif seems like the kind of guy who
He's one of those people
You see this a lot where where like they need closure
and or they think they need closure. You never need closure,
but you like get it in your head that talking to the person would
make it better. Lots of people are like this. And it's like,
"No, it won't. No, it won't. It's going to feed your obsession.
You need to do something else. You need to do anything else."
Right? And so I think he was in that loop where he's like trying
to have a final conversation.
I get it. Happens everybody, but not >> that she was morally
compelled to speak to the public about Mizkif's treatment of
her and others.
We go D-day. On October 25th, 2025,
Emi hosted a live stream on Twitch and later posted in her YouTube
account. A true and correct copy of Emi's entire live stream
is attached to the declaration of Emi's you know Emi's declaration,
exhibit one. Now, here's the thing, guys. It's important for
her to get the entire live stream in there so the judge can have
context. You're going to hear this word, gist. You have to have
the gist of the statement.
And it's it's basically for to determine if defamation occurred.
For the court's convenience, a transcript of the live stream
is also attached to the to Emi's Now, I actually think like if
they get to discovery, if this isn't just
I do actually think
Asmongold and Tectone's
DMs could potentially get They seem super material, right?
What should be included in here? And I I again, we haven't covered
the entire lawsuit, which is a little unfortunate. But if I were
Mizkif, I think it's critical
that you focus on the fact that they talked about how they had
a nuke for months
that they were going to get you, that they had a nuke on you,
right? That does actually That could lead one to believe that
they discussed this and they colluded in some way to talk about
this assault allegation, right? And then Emiru comes in and says,
"Well, this is just my feeling." It's like, "Eh." If you got
If you guys have like DMs colluding with amongst each other that
you're going to go and destroy this guy's life, like that's [__]
That's pretty crazy, man.
Where Asmongold and Tectone or where Asmongold and Tectone, the
ones reporting this behind-the-scenes info to
Oh, no, I don't know that you know it's Asmongold and Tectone.
It could It's probably NMP or probably other people. Some of
the behind-the-scenes stuff, yeah, it could be anybody. Could
literally be anybody. whose declaration at exhibit two. This
is the live stream that forms the basis of the first amended
complaint, which is true. He literally looked at her statement
and said this is defamation. He looked at Asmongold's reaction
to his stream and said this is defamation. So you really only
got to
three videos. Mizkif Emiru's original statement, Mizkif's original
response, and Asmongold reacting to Mizkif. Those are the only
three videos that the court, I guess, has been submitted to the
court to look at. Nothing else. So if you have other information
where Mizkif said this or Emiru said that or Asmongold said that,
it's not going to be considered because one, no one has tried
to get anything outside of that into evidence, if you will. Even
though this is not like the discovery phase, this is like, "Hey,
this is what we want you guys to consider." So, we have that.
In Emiru's livestream, she provides a brief update on the status
of the recent incident at TwitchCon and then delves into the
history between herself and Mizkif. She refers to him as Mizkif,
his online persona. She describes their fractured romantic relationship
and details the repeated instances of physical and emotional
abuse she suffered at his hands. She was emotional, often to
the point of tears,
I this right here, even in the lawsuit, is like not true.
Is there a Is there an instance of physical abuse that he does?
It's like
I mean, that again, that feels like it's That might not be defamation
per se cuz you're not necessarily talking about a crime, but
it's like the phone thing is the only thing, right? I think that's
the only physical abuse. There's like emotional abuse in some
ways, right? But I think it's like literally just the phone thing.
But like the phone Didn't he like smash Yeah, but that's not
emotional That's not physical abuse, right? Like physical abuse
tends to mean you're putting your hands on somebody.
Now, is it a Is it a type of co- like coercion, intimidation?
Sure.
But I do not think that's the correct term to use. This This
feels like
I And I I understand how you could maybe try to make that work
or make it fit, but being like, "Oh, well, he uses physicality
to intimidate" I don't know, man. I don't think so.
I don't think so. >> by their relationship, by the harm
he has caused her for years. Now, shortly thereafter, Mizkif
responded with a stream of his own. For more than 30 minutes,
Mizkif complained about Emiru, criticized her, insulted her,
and encouraged his followers to do the same. He was rude, offensive,
and cruel to his former partner. A true and correct copy of Mizkif's
entire livestream is attached to Emiru's declaration. For the
court's convenience, a transcript of the live stream is attached
to Emiru's declaration exhibit five. So, here's the thing, right?
This is actually I said it was a good strategy because Mizkif
does not want his original live stream to be be
put in or considered. He only wants the statements that he made
or that he considers defamatory to be considered. So, you have
this little back and forth. So, now you have Emiru saying, "Hey,
put in his live stream." I would say the
If they If this goes any further, and I don't know that it will,
but if this goes any further,
I do think the bunny stuff comes up, and that makes him look
real bad. I don't know if it like is legally relevant,
but like the idea that essentially people came up beforehand
and said, "He He blackmailed her with this bunny stuff, and I
think he's going to make this up." And then he came out and he's
"This [__] killed her bunnies."
>> It's just not a good look. I appreciate the level of
commitment it takes to follow through on it, but it's like not
a good look for almost any human being, okay? You have Asmongold
saying, "Put in his live stream." And Asmongold saying, "Put
in my whole live stream." So, and she's going to like piggyback
on that. So, what's happening is it's is literally a two-v-one,
and Emiru has the upper hand because she's responding last. So,
she can see where Asmongold may have fell short in his responses,
had more time to formulate a strategy, and she is literally about
to attack
a lot of Mizkif's amended complaint
with a small contingency plan if it does not get dismissed.
Um on a motion to dismiss, the court may consider the complaint,
any documents attached to the complaint, and any documents attached
to the motion to dismiss that are central to the complaint and
referenced by the complaint, which it is. >> Right. So,
and she has, you know, this case law to this this
court case to support why it should be included. And typically,
when you have a court case to say to support your rationale,
it's hard for the judge to be like, "Oh, no, this this doesn't
apply." Because you got legal precedents is what they call it.
And remember, guys, I'm Um, just keep coping. I do not think
even if you have legitimate evidence, I do think there's like
a there is something kind of wrong with you say don't say anything
or else I'm going to leak stuff on you. I I do think that's sort
of that's sort of the definition of blackmail, right? You you
like literally say you have an ask, you make the ask, and you
say if you don't follow through on my ask, I'm going to hurt
you in some Now, that could be publishing the truth, but I do
believe that's still blackmail.
But I'm guessing they also don't have like perfect perfectly
recorded statements, and it could be vague, and
right? No, I mean we have people who would testify to the ask,
I think, because it was Emiru's manager, but I don't think we
have proof of the ask.
Yet, shockingly amongst the insulting Although, Mizkif might
have Mizkif might have said like, well, here's what I
And I if I recall correctly, I do believe I was like, oh, you
shouldn't have said
Should not have said that.
If I recall correctly, he said something like, I did talk to
her, but I was just like, listen, if you if you publish that
stuff, I'm going to have to publish some stuff about you.
stop talking. [laughter] Stop talking. Stop talking. You got
to stop talking. In crew comments, Mizkif made a few surprising
admissions. Below is a collection of exact quotes from Mizkif's
live stream, unlike the first amended complaint complaint. Emiru
presents full quotes without heavy editing and interpretation.
words, he was leaving stuff out. Now, if you want to read this,
please pause it, read it, have at it, but for the purposes of
going through it, we're just going to kind of stick to some
Um, I don't think if if they included this quote with the phone
thing, I don't think the phone thing matters cuz I uh, you know,
Emiru gave enough context for the phone thing, I think for any
reasonable person to just sort of like go like that could be
something maybe, but almost certainly not.
Right? Like I could work that into I could see how there could
be like a pattern of um
like disregarding your partner in a way that makes them unhappy
and then eventually because they're like telling you don't do
this cuz something bad's going to happen and then the bad thing
eventually happens. There's maybe some but I think she gave enough
context there for most people to just dismiss. Some of the highlights
that doesn't mean potatoes. So,
okay? Remember this whole the plus the him throwing the phone
at the bed. He would say he would throw the phone at the bed
right before a shower and guess what? He said she did tell me
she got a bruise from it and I stopped. Remember when she said,
"Hey, I got a black eye." Not a You know a black eye is a bruise,
but that's a that's a clever way if you will of downplaying a
black eye. It's different saying a bruise versus black eye. Black
eye like, "Ooh." Bruise is like, "Oh, she's got a
She bruises easily. What do you want me to do? I I I Anyway,
anyway. Now, another thing. Anyway, anyway. This is his statement.
In regards to being controlling, I told her many things. I told
her to dress odor, to stop wearing pajamas, to stop talking about
stalkers and schizos. As a whole, stop talking about past relationships.
And yes, I didn't want her to travel without me. I also said
that I didn't want her to hang out with specific people. And
at the end of the day, if someone says you're controlling, that's
not a statement of fact. That's an opinion. So, I don't see how
anyone can say, "Well, she said I was controlling. That's defamation."
What? And then you on top of that, he literally says out of his
words, "I know I was controlling."
Seems to be in agreement.
And actually ended the effing I feel like this should just be
a defamation per se case and it should be that she claimed I
assaulted her. She claimed I was like a
like I was criminal and she herself didn't believe this.
I think that's all it should really be, right? I don't know why
these other statements come up. I mean, I know why these other
statements come up because Miz really hates the label and he
really wants to prove something. He probably went to a lawyer
to find someone who could I I feel like in my head he probably
got turned away by a couple lawyers. He probably had to go to
some like fairly
some flexible
some lawyer who's flexible morally, okay, to take this case on
cuz I swear I feel like a lot of lawyers would look at this and
just go, "Dude, you got no no real shot at this." Except maybe
on the sexual assault thing. in relationship, but I was confused
as a person and I'm sorry I didn't. I'm sorry things got to this
point. The last 9 months of this, we going to go back to that.
We going to go back to that, okay? Now, there's some stuff there's
like, you know, these right here, right? These little statements
right here at the Uh footnotes. Imaru's livestream repeatedly
quoted in the first amended complaint all through never although
never attached in full. So, in other words, yeah, he quoted her
livestream, but he didn't provide it to the court. Why is that?
You tell me. Uh it goes on to say, "In paragraphs 23 to 33, the
first amended complaint alleges Asmongold engaged in defamation
by commenting on Mizkif's livestream. A the very same livestream
attached in exhibit 4 to the Imaru's declaration. As explained
in detail, Asmongold's reply in short of his motion to dismiss
the first amended complaint, Asmongold's livestream is a picture-in-picture
commentary of Mizkif's livestream, Asmongold reacting to Mizkif's
livestream in real time.
Right? Mizkif's livestream is a critical factual puzzle piece
the court must consider when evaluating the weakness in the first
amended complaint.
this is more pressure for the judge to consider all three videos
and not just what the quotes that Mizkif for, you know, lack
of a better word, cherry-picked from both of their livestreams
to file a defamation lawsuit. And in all honesty, like
does his legal team This is like fine. I think maybe they just
wanted to try something and they tried it. I do think the full
livestream should be be for context, but
like I'm not I'm not shocked that somebody would only give the
best parts for them. If you filed that defamation lawsuit and
then you have to amend it almost
what are they doing? Like are they hosing them? I dude, it's
so normal to amend your complaint. It's like literally something
every court allows. It's like totally normal. I I don't think
this means anything.
It could be that like so what I assume happened here or what
you could assume happened is basically Mizkif wants them to stop
talking about him and filing the lawsuit is a good way to just
get them to be wary about talking about you, right? So they could
file something to get it in knowing they could amend, right?
That's probably what they're doing. I would imagine. Like, hey,
um these people keep yapping about me. I really don't like it.
So I'm going to file the lawsuit, right? The lawyer says, "Okay,
we'll file the lawsuit." And then they'll be a little more like
their lawyers will tell them, "Don't don't talk about this guy.
Like don't give them any ammo. Don't say something that could
potentially get you in trouble in court. Just shut the [__]
up about them until we get the lawsuit figured out." Or is there
are they saying this is standard? So me, I am in support of all
three live streams being considered. I think that's fair. To
all parties. To all parties, not just Amouranth or Asmongold.
So here we go. I know I was controlling the last 9 months of
this relationship thing has gotten extremely effing toxic.
More statements from Mizkif. And she's basically trying to say,
"Everything I'm accused of defaming him, he confirmed." "She
would throw clothes or plushies at me and I punched holes in
the walls and slammed doors in aggression." So if you if she
accuses him of punching holes in the wall and he says that's
defamation
and then you go on stream and say, "Hey, I punched holes in the
walls and slammed doors in aggression." How is how is that defamation?
That That's all she's trying to do.
Uh so I see all these quotes. I don't actually know
to be honest with you and I don't know if Henry went and found
this.
I would be shocked if they included quotes about him punching
holes in walls as defamation claims.
I would just be totally shocked. Like it seems like she's To
me, what it looks like is they know that this is going to be
read for content by a bunch of streamers, and so they're getting
all of the bad moments for Mizkif into the content, right?
Is that not like clearly and obviously what they're doing?
I don't see why Mizkif would It wouldn't make any sense to me
if he highlighted where she said he punched holes in the and
then he was like, "Oh, well, that's defamation." Knowing that
he actually posted a stream where he admitted to punching holes
in the walls. Uh we cuddled for about 30 minutes and started
to kiss. She said that she was okay with this on her stream,
and I started to advance to the next stage because I thought
that's what she wanted. She yelped, and I immediately sprung
up and was scared if I did anything wrong or did it wrong in
general. I got scared and left the house. I apologize if I made
Amy uncomfortable for me not saying sorry, and I wish I said
sorry back then. But we got back together soon
More quotes from Mizkif, "I'm a horrible boyfriend. I have lots
of messages that
that I have that I'm
uh they do get back together afterwards. That doesn't necessarily
mean this wasn't assault,
but to be honest, like it seemed pretty tenuous as an assault
allegation to begin with to me. Um I wouldn't say this changes
my mind at all that you got back together
People get back together with somebody who like punches their
[__] face in,
Like women get back together with dudes who break their nose.
It's not really indicative of It's It's not in and of itself
indicative of much. It really isn't. I'm going to expose as time
goes on because I do believe that this is a time to go effing
buck wild. And imagine trying to tell a judge you just clip farmed.
Imagine you say, "Oh, I was just clip farming. I didn't mean
about that."
Well, if you were just clip farming, then they were just clip
farming, too, right? It has to go both ways. I don't think that's
going to be his defense, but this is not This is not paint him
in the best of lights. If Emi were to say anything about me,
I would say something back. This was his motto. Okay, if
it was if she ever said anything, I would say something as well.
So, it's going to be this back and forth. This is, you know,
straight from Mizkif's
As with much of Mizkif's statements, this is an entirely fabricated
description of the events that occurred between Emiru and Mizkif.
Emiru was deeply offended and saddened by his vindictive and
callous statements regarding one of the worst events in Emiru's
life.
Wait, was this is about the rabbits?
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Um but I want to make it very clear when
it comes to Emiru, when she says, "I was getting ready to uh
I was uh getting ready to go after her and then I was going to
use her rabbits against her." That was never the plan. My plan
was very for myself was very simple. Oh, we might not have direct
proof of this. So, he made it He never have said anything about
the rabbits, but I'm guessing they knew it was about the rabbits.
Do you guys remember when Asmongold went live and he was like,
"You guys don't even know about Emiru? She had a rabbit that
was paralyzed.
She took It was like a furry potato. She took care of that thing
all the time." Remember when Asmongold did that in his yokel
voice?
She took care of that little potato. She fed it lettuce in front
of me.
Lenny, actually. I didn't even realize started stray into Lenny
there for a second. She I remember Asmongold saying all of this,
okay? I remember it. Brain's a steel trap, okay? And
how did he know that that was going to be what Mizkif brought
forward would be my question. Hello.
Hello, Ruben Rubbin. We really going to hop back on this subject?
Wow, terrible, terrible, terrible donation. Thank you so much,
Ruben Rubbin, for the three. I appreciate it. Guys, we're five
subs away from another hour on the stream. I'm probably going
to go a little longer than that. I'll definitely finish all of
the Mizkif stuff, but I'm going to try to farm a little bit.
I don't want to be here the whole night, so we started with fewer
hours, but if we we don't get anything, I'll definitely finish
the miskif stuff before I go, okay? Promise. Promise.
I sure Asmongold didn't strangle that rabbit in that case. Well,
well.
Honestly, would have been suspicious of that before I did the
Lenny voice. Lenny voice didn't help. >> This is, you know,
straight from Miskif's mouth. As with much of Miskif's statements,
this is an entirely fabricated addictive and callous Can I clarify
what if anything I said to her team at TwitchCon? Question mark.
I said that if she goes after me, then I will go nuclear, and
that is exactly what I said, and that is what's going to happen
because you can't mess with me anymore. I don't have anything
to lose. I'm sorry. I don't I don't
I'm sorry. I don't. Go after me all you want. I have nothing
to lose. I mean, you know, man, he's he's he's going out he's
going out with a bang. And I don't like that she was portraying
that it was just me who was at fault. It was a toxic relationship,
and that's what it was. Emiru's
As we continue, right? So, these are some statements to kind
of like, you know, paint paint a picture for the judge of the
I guess the relationship and maybe what he confirmed during his
live stream. After Emiru and Miskif's live stream, Asmongold
posted a series of live streams of his own in discussing greater
detail in Asmongold's amended motion.
>> Uh Miskif's claim as to Asmongold are similarly weak.
So, like, this is like tag teaming like, oh yeah, we're going
to defend Asmongold, too.
Her legal team is doing that. In addition to OTK Media Inc.,
Mythic Talent Management and King Gaming Labs Inc., ousted Miskif
as a result of his actions towards Emiru and others. Emiru and
others. Emphasis on that. This may come back in cuz remember,
he is suing Emiru, Asmongold, Mythic, OTK,
and King Gaming Labs. So, you have all these different defendants.
Yet, just days after admitting to the world that he was abusive,
controlling, and toxic, Miskif filed a claim against Emiru, among
other claims. Miskif now claims that the behavior he admitted
to and even embraced in his October 26, 2025 live stream is actually
false and Imaru has defamed him by
Yo,
we do the ladder dude. Thank you for the gifted sub. I appreciate
it, man. Thank you. Thank you. Speaking her truth. Emphasis on
her truth. Emphasis on her truth. Mischa is attempting the very
smear campaign he promised in his live stream. He has nothing
to lose and like so many men before him is attempting to use
the court system to intimidate Imaru into silence. I got to see
if they got to if she's trying to appeal to a female judge. When
you say like so many men
Instead of like so many people before? This is This is making
it a men versus a woman thing into silence. And that has happened
before. Powerful men silence, you know, their alleged victims
sometimes. Uh this is his nuclear option. He has been constantly
Oh hold on.
Hello, Alpha Kilo. Thank you for the gifted sub. I appreciate
it. >> harassing Imaru online since filing the lawsuit
while mobilizing his fan base to attack her online.
That's the truthful
I don't think that's happening.
I really don't think that's happening,
Because the weird thing is like she's universally supported.
Also, I thought he was a middling creator. I thought you have
like a way bigger fan base. Did you even notice it through all
the people liking all of your tweets and Well, I mean she doesn't
tweet that
But you know what I mean? Like she's a way bigger creator. I
just don't think I don't think this has happened at all.
I also don't know if he's ever mobilized them specifically to
attack her, but that's not necessarily Usually with a creator,
if they're just going to like open up a start talking about somebody
and like crying about how much they hurt them,
obviously cause an effect, yeah? Yeah, man.
I mean I'm still with my ex-wife right now, but I never I never
talk about her in a negative way online or anytime. Um and what
he is doing Uh-huh. Okay. be sued. All right. Now, is she going
to act on that?
Probably not, but it does not bode well for his case where he
has videos where he's like, "She ruined my life. She lied. She
literally comes up in every live stream." But, you have this
thing called freedom of speech. But, I'm sure his legal team
was like, "Can you stop talking about her?" And he was like,
>> Nope. "No, she ruined my life. I just won't talk about
the case." He has openly stated his goal is to influence the
court of public opinion, which he recently did, and not the court
of law. This case is a sham intended to silence the woman bringing
his misconduct to light. Her lawyer is cooking. Mhm. I don't
like
Do I like that argument? I think this assault thing, given that
she says it's her like emotional opinion or something, I do think
this assault claim was probably too far.
And the concerning thing is
is it's obvious what the nuke here was. The nuke is the assault,
right?
And you had two creators who really hated this guy who were taunting
him for months
about dropping a nuke on his career, right? And that's like clearly
what they're alluding to. And so, it makes it pretty
to me.
What is this? October of 2024?
When when were When were Emiru and Asmongold playing Teamfight
Tactics? Dude, can we go Do I still have that somewhere? Further,
the live stream plainly represents Emiru's emotional truth. Remember
I said emotional truth?
Which is protected and not subject to a claim of defamation.
I know this is going to piss a lot of people off um, because
I was reading it like, "What? Emotional truth?
Alternatively, the court should require plaintiffs to specifically
identify and articulate the exact sentences by Emiru that are
supposedly defamatory without creatively quoting and interpreting
winning words, and identify how and who was harmed by these statements.
Now, like I said, we don't have to read everything. Parts in
green parts in yellow are important, but if you want to pause
the video to read every word, by all means go ahead. It's 72
pages, but the response is really only like two or three pages.
The bulk of the the pages are
transcripts. So, the amended complaint must be dismissed. Why?
Failure to state a complaint claim upon which relief can be granted.
Like, hey, where is the defamatory statement that will qualify
Mizkif for for relief?
She's saying
Uh it's it is everything about See, this is the thing.
Oh, she's actually cooked on this. It's really simple. I wonder
if I should just mention or message Mizkif about it, right? So,
she's saying I made no statement that was like actually
It's like, well, what you did do was you basically said you were
talking about assault, and then a couple minutes later you described
a assault. The description in and of itself would not be defamatory
cuz you are describing what you think happened, but the obvious
implication is that it was assault. So, when you say that you
were just describing your feelings, it's not really true. You
were accusing him of assaulting you categorically. I think even
a I think a judge would see this, too.
I really do. is not there. That's That's all this is, and most
of this is just case law to support it. Now, we all know this.
To prevail on a claim of defamation, the plaintiff, Mizkif in
this case, must prove the publication of a false statement of
fact to a third party. Emma was not denying she said the things
that Mizkif said. So, he has that. The defamatory
Publication of a false statement of fact to a third party.
Uh
that the defamatory that was defamatory concerning the plaintiff.
Yes. So, first one little difficult to know for sure. False statement.
Well, a false statement of fact.
It's sort of conditional, but you sort of you've sort of like
proven part one now that you're saying you just believe it was
like emotional speaking you weren't making the allegation.
That was defamatory concerning the plaintiff with the requisite
degree of fault. Now
Uh that that's where the dude I think I think Mizkif might actually
get through on this one. Maybe. Maybe. >> concerning the
plaintiff. The statements were about Mizkif so he has two. Three,
within the requisite degree of fault and damage to some extent.
Mhm. She did say it but was it false? Was it a statement of fact?
Those are things you have to consider. This is right here uh
you know TFT uh Teamfight Tactics. Uh I don't know how I got
involved playing that game.
So this is Emiru and Asmongold playing this game together. Okay.
>> Is that Rich Campbell? Didn't he wrote? What I've been
doing on my my days off recently is I usually just have to be
on my computer to like do like work. I'll just buy my friends.
I'll buy them games that I like playing and make them stream
it for me on Discord. I'm going to be honest. Like I was on a
Discord call with somebody. Like I was extremely PO'd to them.
Dude, I still think this is so funny how like how absolutely
schizophrenic this What is this supposed to prove? That they
play games together off Hold on. Wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait. Legitimate gamer? It's It's literally just an Emiru
schizo who is
It's just an Emiru schizo who is basically saying they're dating,
right?
Which I think there's a little bit to >> 7:30 in the morning,
all right? I stayed up so late last night. Hey, I played three
games of Mega Bomb with my friend and I got I got on Discord
and I was like I I I was screen sharing and I just kept dying
on map one. I got to Aspen's party. Uh your tweet is deleted
there. Please don't be a little liar. >> to do that yet.
I don't know. Um I'm going to probably lay down and take a nap
and I'll be back on tomorrow.
Hello. Hello. How's it going?
Are you leaving?
I'm probably going to give this I'll give the second one away
to someone. I don't know who yet. This I picked this one up last
night uh from the store. Did you get a Switch, too? No, I didn't.
I went to a It's actually kind of funny. I went to the midnight
release of the Switch last night with somebody else, and they
got their Switch, but I didn't get my Switch. And so I got home
I got home about like probably 3:00 in the morning almost. No,
no, no, 2:00 2:00 2:00 cuz I had I had to do a meeting at 2:00
a.m. Actually, I didn't buy it. It was given to me. I I I have
a Switch,
And I will repay that debt.
I'm sorry. It like
It got I got 65 Zach raw raids. >> Uh true stuff, absolutely.
You don't want you want to be sent from someone who's not your
girlfriend? Well, I mean sometimes maybe maybe to get her, you
know, like you got to capture them, right? It's like you you
know, like whenever you're hunting and like you're trying to
capture like I'm sorry.
When he says like I'm staying up until 3:00 a.m. playing games
with this
If it's a person in the opposite sex, I feel like there's something
going on there, okay? You're playing games till 3:00 a.m. with
the boys, that could be innocuous. You're playing 3:00 a.m. You're
playing games at 3:00 a.m. in with some woman,
ah, come on. Come come on.
Come on. You're both You're both like massive creators, okay?
And you're playing games at 3:00 a.m. off stream.
You If this was just like your friends, you could easily just
stream it together, right? Make a bunch of money, have fun with
your chats.
I feel like an But no, hold on. I say that there is something
to be said for just playing off stream. Um I literally just said
playing with the boys gummy verse totally different. Totally
different. Obviously different.
Obviously totally different. You're weird. Like a right right
or something like that or a like you could say uh you put um
food under a box, right? And then like as soon as they get in
the box, you get the box, right? You can't I hate to say this,
but if you're lying to a girl, the best way to do it is to emotionally
manipulate them. If you can activate their emotions on something,
you can tell them anything that they want to hear, and you can
get them to believe it, right?
Hey man, if more people wanted to play games with us at 3:00
a.m. who are creators,
I would I would let them in the group, okay?
Unfortunately, that's when the stream ends and that's when I
got time to play video games. So, what am I supposed to Oh, dude.
>> Dude, can I
Dude, absolutely die about that. That's [__] crazy.
That's [__] crazy, chat.
I do This is This is kind of unrelated except it's probably just
showing when her games were that you could such that you could
look them up and then find that she was playing with Asmongold.
I do think Oh, am I crazy?
Am I crazy that it seems like she sees something here that she's
like, I shouldn't have shown this.
She's like watching.
She's looking for her games.
Oh. Oh.
No, mine's not mine's not like that. I I wouldn't find
Yeah, I know. That's what I think is she basically just gave
away her game history in a way that those kids are are totally
going to go look for.
Okay. So, all of that was to just show that they were hanging
out. Now, that is a little bit after the allegations were made.
What I would be What I would wonder is if you go look at her
OP.GG
and you scroll back even further, do you see that they were playing
around the time of around October before Emiru put
Huh. Before she put the statement out, were they talking a lot?
So, I kind of wonder what they were talking about. Is all. You
know?
You know what I'm saying? >> This gave damaged. Can you
show losses?
Was there malice? Did she openly make a statement that she knew
was false
made it anyway. If a statement is not verifiable and false, it
is not
Ms. Guiffre intentionally omits and misrepresents context of
Imaru's statements. This is the reason why it should be dismissed.
And we don't have to read all of this cuz it's only a couple
parts. In order to prevail on his claim of defamation, Ms. Guiffre
must state direct allegations
articulating the exact nature of the statements at issue, how
they were false, and why they are capable of defamatory meaning.
However, the first amended complaint is a little more than
Okay, we got to hold on. I got to go and find this now. She lied
basically She lied and basically accused Ronaldo of psychological
and domestic abuse, stalking and harassment, assault, and threats
of blackmail. These slighter's accusations were made Yeah, that's
literally them. Wait. Hold on. I do think you should probably
try to stick to the assault part as like the clearly false thing.
This is like
Stalking and harassment
Psychological domestic abuse debatable, okay?
I think the assault part is where you actually have to zoom in
and and see that there's really no way she could defend that.
That's probably the one you have to go and get a lot closer on,
okay?
For example, in her own description of the purported assault
she Okay.
It's weird that she come out and say like, "Oh, well, I didn't
say that." Or I didn't make that allegation directly. I was just
describing my feelings.
I have to go I have to go find her response now. Is her motion
to dismiss probably? Okay.
Ms. Guiffre must state direct allegations articulating the nature
of the exact statements at issue. Well, he
He He absolutely did.
Where does she mention so hold on? So Chunk respectfully requests
the court make to take judicial notice of exhibits one to five
attached to Chunk's declaration in considering this instant motion
to dismiss.
Get extremely toxic.
So I noticed she doesn't address these assault quote directly.
I do think that hurts her, right? Like the substan- the actual
substantial part of this is when she says
when when she says she's describing assault and then she goes
on to describe what sounds like a sexual assault, there's a connection
there and I think they're just playing dumb in this in this filing.
Yeah, I think she's just playing dumb in this in this filing.
I don't understand
So I do think I do think they actually directly state basically
what happened and how it's received as assault and they're sort
of just going around the edges and other than the sexual assault
you can argue the other ones. That's why I wouldn't have included
them personally. I guess maybe you want to throw everything against
the wall, but I do think the sexual assault thing, yeah, that's
a big one. >> The big one. statements by Imaru during the
October 25th, 2025 live stream that were purportedly defamatory
towards Mizkif. However, Mizkif intentionally omits to inform
the court the fact that Imaru's live stream was nearly 90 minutes
long. Why would he? Why would he be like, "Hey, yeah, this is
a 90-minute live stream and we, you know, we doing what we do."
Uh you got that.
Mizkif selectively quoted single words and fragments out of a
90-minute live stream in order to dramatize and manipulate the
actual context of the live stream. Now, you can actually go look
at it
like let's just take this one for example cuz this one didn't
come up. That at a party she felt Mizkif was following her and
monitoring her and watching her and then later made eye contact
with her and said, "Ooh." Is this defamatory? Like is this
Actually stuff like that. All right, keep going.
even a Now, so that's their fault for using the statements like
those statements directly, those quotes. >> statement is
not defamatory if the context of those statements discloses that
they reflect an opinion. So, if you think Mizkif was following
you,
discloses that they reflect an opinion. It's going to come down
to this assault. We could listen to how she describes it again.
If she describes it like
she doesn't at the beginning. She describes it like hesitantly
or says, "Well, I don't really know. I guess it was This is my
opinion on how this went down or something." That is your opinion,
and Mizkif is like, "Well, I wasn't following you. I just coincidentally
at the same party." And that's not necessarily defamatory, and
she has a legal case to support that.
As we continue, the first amended complaint must be dismissed
because Mizkif complete Can you show it again? I don't remember
it well. Can I show it one again? >> provide the context
of Amour's statements, which he didn't provide much context.
Just even if you're the biggest Mizkif
Think about that. Of the litany of supposedly defamatory statements,
Mizkif includes only a single full sentence quote at paragraph
19. The remaining statements alleged in the first amended complaint
are chopped and edited to the point where the quotes have no
meaning. For example,
Mizkif claims in at paragraph 20 that Mizkif was screaming at
her due to her
That bizarre statement is a complete quote from the first Amour
is making the essay claim. Oh, sure. Yeah, this is very easy.
Today, I'm finally going to be opening up about
the psychological and domestic abuse, stalking and harassment,
assault, and threats of blackmail that Mizkif has done towards
me, and some of these issues which are still ongoing.
For the entirety of this year, I've So, like that's pretty cut
and dry right there, right? She claims she was assaulted by Mizkif.
She goes on to describe what sounds like a simple assault by
Mizkif.
it's only defamation if she doesn't believe she was insulted.
Now, she could say she believes she's insulted, but then in in
the filing, there's something here where she says it's like a
defensible The lawyers argue it's a defensible like emotional
opinion or something, which I would agree with if she didn't
like outside of the emotional story state she was insulted. Now,
I'm curious, has she been telling other people that she was insulted?
Because I think what I what I just heard Henry say about this
um about this precedent is
what is it? Um
Oh, maybe it's up here a little bit. But, it's like basically
you can defend an opinion so long as you disclose obviously that
it's an opinion, right?
You have to disclose that it's being that it is an opinion
in some way. As in you're not stating it as a fact, but it sure
sounds like she stated it as an as a fact, right? submit a complaint.
That is the entire sub paragraph word for word. Oh my god.
I think we can find it, right? The cat thing right here. That
Rinaldo was screaming at her due to her cat. You see it? You
like, wait, what? Yeah. He said that's defamatory.
This strange claim is made with no context and no explanation.
The court is left to guess what due to the cat means, what Imeru
supposedly said, or why screaming at someone due to her cat is
supposed supposed to be a false statement capable of defamatory
meaning as is required for a defamation claim.
Um oh, her statement can be interpreted as all of these things
that I am saying are currently under dispute.
Similarly, Miersch claims that it was defamatory when Imeru said
at a party she felt Miersch was following her, monitoring her,
watching her, and then later make eye contact with her and said,
"Ooh."
>> I mean, I'm just just think about it. Say "Ooh." Okay?
Again, Mizkif
strings together specific words to Uh by the way, that's like
the context for that is Mizkif There's like a party and Mizkif
was like going to another room cuz he was looking for somebody
or something. I don't know if I don't know what he was doing,
okay? But he he said he was looking for like a different room.
He's trying to go to a different room. And he goes to this room
and he opens the door and it's like NMP, somebody else, maybe
Emily or something, and then Emiru are in there. And he goes,
"Uh you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you
you you you you Uh-oh. Oops. Guess this is Guess this room isn't
for me." And then he walks
That's like the uh ooh ooh
my bad. I'll You guys all hate me. I'll just leave. I'll just
see myself out. Goodbye. pick that out of Emiru's live stream
to make an implication that Emiru said something defamatory,
yet does not provide the full quote. Regardless, Mizkif claims
in this sub paragraph simply make no sense, which I would agree
with. said "Ooh."
>> He said "Ooh." Even if Emiru's statement was false,
which it was not, admitted by Mizkif himself, how is a statement
that someone followed her around the room, made eye contact,
and then said "Ooh" a statement capable of defamatory meaning?
What damage could that statement possibly cause to Mizkif? No
reasonable person of ordinary intelligence would ever believe
that statement to be capable of defamatory
>> You have to be some kind of
to think that works. I do think the only part that feels important
is going to be the section
that is talking about like her feeling that she's doing like
a feeling
Yeah, yeah, yeah, this one. Protected emotional truth. What is
this?
What is this [__] Okay? This is really all we need
here. Is this last part.
Texas law has long held that even a verifiable false statement
is not defamation if the context of that statement reveals that
the statement was merely a reflection of an opinion,
not a statement of fact.
Now, I understand what this means, right? That like
like this is like
somebody who's like let's say it's the same streamer and she
goes like Miss Keffiyeh, you raped me.
I don't know if it meets the definition. I'm just saying like
this is how I felt. If she did something that was like like going
and making
like it contextually
not sound like a direct thing, right? If she was doing that,
then I'd understand invoking this
but I don't hear [snorts] that when she says that she was assaulted.
I hear nothing like that, to be honest with you. Now, there is
like an emotional
telling of the story,
but when she just makes the claim before she's getting emotional,
before she's recounting events, she does just make a claim flat
out that she was assaulted.
I I don't know
how you get around that, but we'll see what the precedent say.
See
this lawsuit
right here.
we got another one. The Court of Appeals first district recently
took up this exact issue in the case strikingly similar to one
at the bar.
In Vincent v. Guerrero,
a daughter made a TikTok video in which she accused her stepfather
of SA and accused her mother, a famous wrestler, of knowing about
the assault and refusing to do anything to protect her.
Right there.
The mother of the stepfather
filed a lawsuit alleging that the
claims constituted defamation because she accused the stepfather
of a crime of essay and that the mother of the crime of tampering
with a witness.
There, the daughter was able to take advantage of Texas Citizens
Participation Act
expedited procedures to move to dismiss defamation claims filed
by her mother and stepfather.
Now, here is what you guys
have to understand.
Here, Miss K filed the case in federal court in order to avoid
the TCPA
because the TCPA would give Immeru
and other defendants the opportunity to actually address his
false claims
and merits and end this case quickly.
I don't think they're making the argument, though.
I So,
I'm guessing if you Oh, we might have to look into this. Do we
have to Do we actually have to delve deeper and see what this
precedent says? We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. It
actually delves deeper itself. Cuz I I don't think they made
the argument yet. >> This is semantics. The reason why
this is filed in federal court is because all above over 75,000,
it has to go federal. Now, could it be that he was truly trying
to avoid the TCPA?
Sure. It could That could be the case. But, any claim above $75,000
is going to be heard in federal court. Not, you know, not your
state. I mean, not your civil your your your county court. It's
going to be federal. In Bentsen, the mother >> Hold on.
I see a 9-minute video down here. The war was necessary. The
way Trump did it wasn't. Sam Harris. Ooh.
The war was necessary. Sam Harris taking out his old dusting
off his old positions. Radical Islamic terror, eh? Interesting.
Might have to take a look at that. claimed that the daughter
made several false and defamatory statements that seeming seemed
factually verifiable on their face. The allegation of SA against
the father, the step father, including that that the mother knew
her daughter had been SA by her step father but did not care
to characterize the SA as a mistake and three, told her daughter
that the assault was not the mother's problem.
Four, failed to protect daughter from SA. Five, abandoned her
daughter in support of the step father who she knew had SA'd
her daughter. So these are some
right there to make.
As we can go on, the court analyzed the entire context of the
video noting that the daughter expressed her unhappiness with
the
oh, how do I describe this? I do feel like it's really hard to
make this
when you know when you make when you make the the like prepared
statement at the beginning. It feels prepared. Like she'd written
it down.
That you are talking about
It just feels so different, man.
estrangement between her and her mother. The court held that
entire context showed that the daughter's statements were not
actionable because she was sharing her personal
viewpoint.
I.E. An example, her own emotional truth,
not purported facts.
Now, I Dude, the really unfortunate thing here is Okay, that's
interesting or whatever.
So this would be maybe dismissible under this previous thing
that's not even a precedent that could be used here,
So hold on. First of all, is this entire thing
expedited procedures? I can't tell if this TCPA is what includes
the emotional fact part
or not.
Right? Or if if that's just a way to get an expedited like looking
to the factual nature of the statements.
Right? I can't tell which one it is. If it's just looking into
the factual nature of the statements in some expedited fashion,
then it's not really relevant. The emotional fact thing holds
up no matter what.
Cuz are they double They're like double referencing Benson in
the same thing.
These should be separated, I think, if they're different arguments.
If they're the same argument, then the the Texas Citizens Participation
Act gives you the emotional fact thing, but I don't think it
does. I think this is poorly written. You You I
I feel like if you're going to cite this case for two different
reasons, they should be in different things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. If you If you are citing this
Yeah, it just feels odd. Anyway, we keep >> Was not the
mother's problem.
Sorry, we are forward past this. ported fat.
This is wild.
This is a real court case. And guess what? What is Emaru arguing?
Hey,
I know I said some stuff that could be verifiable in his face
whether he has So, oh, here's another thing.
I think there's going to be a big difference in the nature of
the of the
Like if you're arguing against this, you argue the nature of
the media. That a TikTok video is something you shoot on the
fly, there's no script, it's just like off the cuff, you do get
emotional, you could say something out of order. The live stream
was likely scripted.
The scripting of the live stream makes it far different than
just emotional truth. You have decided to say these words out
loud.
Say me or not, whether he's stalking me or not.
That was my emotional >> Where says it was unscripted?
TELL ME OTHERWISE. THE ONLY PROBLEM is
That's not good cuz I feel like you see her eyes in a lot of
cases.
Man, it's like looking down. What is
What is that?
What is that in her lap?
What's in her lap right there?
Amiru said she had a script and notes.
Ain't no way she said
So, uh yeah, if if it seems like can see I wrote out my notes
and
>> No way the lawyer argues that. There's no way the lawyer
argues that. Get the [__] out of here, bro. Not only
that, I'll show >> a She's a better to say it's Oh, even
more notes. So, uh yeah, if if it seems like I'm like reading
a script or something, it's cuz I I wrote super detailed notes
because I wanted to make sure I didn't miss anything. Uh so Uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
There's no way this lawyer just did Bro, there's no way the lawyer
argues it's The TCPA don't apply. This is federal court.
it's going to be up to the judge to to figure out Um unfortunately,
as much as you might think this sweatpants freedom, I do believe
that when she So, if it looks like I'm reading a script or whatever,
I've got super detailed notes. And then once she gets to reading
these super detailed notes, which will come in this section,
she's literally looking directly at her notes, I think. Today,
I'm finally going to Like Like she is explicitly reading directly
from her notebook while she says this part. >> about the
psychological and domestic abuse, stalking and harassment, sexual
assault, and threats of blackmail that Miss Kip has done towards
me and some of these issues which are still ongoing.
obviously reading right here.
Right? She's obviously reading right
750 mentions the lawyer cuz I do think she probably wrote this
down so as not to get in legal trouble. All of the delays and
like refusal to work with the Um and yeah, it's um it's still
ongoing. I can't like say too much about it. Like all the stuff
I'm saying obviously I like ran by my lawyer and stuff. Um Dude,
your your lawyer might [__] suck.
Your your lawyer might [__] it's Your lawyer might
have you super badly.
I Maybe and I don't know, maybe it won't be that bad or maybe
it's not really an admission cuz I do think
when you say it's your emotional truth, it also doesn't mean
that you don't believe it happened or you're not making the allegation.
Right? And if she just cuz she says, "Well, this is the emotional
truth." It's the argument they make.
And people are painting that as a walk
People are painting that as a walk back. I think what she has
to do is just lean into saying, "No, I was assaulted." That's
what she would have to do here, right?
Now, I don't think she would be found I don't think Miskif would
be found guilty or liable or anything in any sense for the events
that unfolded, but I don't think it's insane to believe that
she was for her to believe that she was assaulted,
right? I don't think that's insane and for her to say as much.
I don't think any of those things are >> be your paypig.
>> on. Listen. Listening. >> Ruben Ruben donated
$3.
Essays by Miskif and her lawyer.
Oh, Jesus. Okay. Now I get it. Thank you. Thank you very much
Ruben Ruben. Disgusting, but thank you. I appreciate
No, she would have to lean into saying she was assaulted. That
she believes she was assaulted. That she she feels that she didn't
consent and
like I don't think it rises to assault cuz there is some amount
of like going, you know, up and down the escalation ladder in
terms of
you know, things you do with a partner.
And I I think it's like fairly reasonable for Miss Gift to go
there. I know some people totally disagree. Unfortunately, wires
get crossed in situations like that. I don't think it's like
totally crazy.
Um if they had no previous relationship, it would be totally
crazy. Like there's no way you could make that leap if you hadn't
been together for a long period of time. They'd been together
for a long period of time. What is that fit, bro? I believe I
am one of Emiru's bunnies. I'm supposed to be one of the Emmy
bunnies, okay?
Cuz you've never seen the
Uh if you if you're squeamish, don't look, okay? But this is
what happened to me, okay? This is my story. This is what happened
to me.
I'm here to tell you my story today. Trigger warning. You you
kind of get the gist of it. If you want to pause it, have Oh,
this lawyer lying is actually really
This lawyer lying is actually really bad. This whole precedent
doesn't work.
Yeah, these uh this none of this works. What was the first argument
they made? There were two arguments. The first argument was
Let me see here. The first argument was Miss Rendino intentionally
omits and misrepresents the context. I don't think I don't think
either of these work. I think both of their actual arguments
don't work. I think this is very easily defeated by a response,
a reply, or whatever.
I think like it it actually feels like
they do appropriate appropriately contextualize the assault comments.
Almost everything else could go. And then they know that this
specifically they're trying to deal with the assault comments.
I think
out the window, too. I think this defense is out the window.
Okay, but they have I guess they have other ones as well. And
the complaint must be dismissed as to Miskif Enterprises because
first Okay, there's other stuff in here. I don't know how much
we care about the other stuff. That's all kind of
with the context of the entire 90-minute live stream, it's clear
that Emiru was telling her own emotional truth, explaining how
their relationship came to an end and struggles Emiru endured
during the relationship. The live stream was sponta-
Um Maximus, I think
Now, I don't know how it works with per se, okay? I don't know
how it works with per se and assault cuz that ultimately is like
a contextual like subjective
It has to do with like your consent, right? I don't think you
would have to prove If you said somebody assaulted you and you
had and you like reasonably complained to somebody around that
time that you were assaulted, you thought you were assaulted,
and then you claimed they assaulted you, I do not believe that
could be defamation per se in Texas. Otherwise, like basically
I think it would be Wouldn't Tekton be able to sue PinkChyu?
Under those same grounds that like it's not necessarily proven
in a court of law yet? Like it's it's It rises to a certain level
of um
of what do you call it? Like a standard of evidence, but
Right? I think the thing that makes this more me more land on
Miskif's side here though is the fact that he just stops right
away. That's like a big deal to me that like it's not it's not
repeatedly violating consent. It's like the second he got the
sense that she was not okay or into it at all, he left. He was
like, "Oh, I Oh, bye. Bye." Like a cat. >> spontaneous,
unedited, and unscripted, underscoring that Emiru was not delivering
a rehearsed narrative, but instead
was speaking openly and vulnerably in the moment. >> her
truth as she experienced it. Like the daughter in the Benson
Does Henry know that this is just a straight-up lie? Emiru's
allegedly defamatory statements were I It's all lies. All total
lies.
That's crazy.
Did the lawyer Yeah, did the lawyer Somebody joked earlier like
the lawyer didn't even bill hours to watch this video. He couldn't
even watch it. Couldn't be bothered.
Bro, he literally said
She literally said she has notes. She's got detailed notes. She
shows the paper with the where the notes are written. She's clearly
reading the notes when she says she was assaulted. either non-actionable
statements of opinion
or merely opinions or masquerading as facts. So,
what does it say? In Mero's opinion,
she was essayed. In Mero's opinion,
she was stalked. In Mero's opinion,
she
abused by Misquif.
That's her opinion
based on her emotional truth.
what do you do with that?
What do you do with that? This is some news to me, man. That's
false. She said on stream she spoke to a lawyer and was reading
from notes. I know she was reading from notes, but was she reading
just bullet points?
Was she reading a script?
He For that part, I do believe she's reading a script.
Like for that part, I believe the whole
that whole section right there is scripted. She's looking, she's
reading. You know.
Why wouldn't Why wouldn't Henry just pull it up? >> Yeah, I'm
going to have to figure that out. Or the judge is going to have
to figure that out.
But I you know, that's a that's a smooth little defense right
there. For example, she discussed at length the pain she felt
that her partner, whom she cared for deeply, whose approval she
craved, repeatedly pun- But they li- listen, they don't even
hit They don't even hint
the live stream was spontaneous. No, it wasn't. She took notes.
She planned a
Even if it was just bullet points, it's not spontaneous. It's
unedited, sure it's a live stream, it's unscripted. No, it's
not. Again, notes underscoring that she wasn't not delivering
a rehearsed
She was. She did. She absolutely did. It was a rehearsed narrative.
That doesn't mean it couldn't have gotten That doesn't mean that
she wasn't open or vulnerable, but it was absolutely a rehearsed
narrative that she wrote down. punished for her success.
And based on the fact that those other were talking about a nuke
repeatedly. Oh
I didn't think Mischa had any chance. He might actually have
a chance on this
And I think it it comes down to
you got to see what what Asmongold and Detect were saying, I
guess, about this
hate He might He's probably not going to have a chance, but I
feel like it seems pretty evident to me that she was telling
them about telling those two about it.
it's actually crazy. So, basically,
I felt
like I was kind of stuck in a loop where I felt like I had to
constantly perform and like lose my value and not be thrown away,
but at the same time, if I ever perform too well, I was going
to be punished for it. And it just felt like a very rough
You go live and say someone SA'd you, you better be able to prove
that in civil court.
Uh I don't know, man.
well, Trucker Joe, I've got those DMs that you're talking about.
So, yes, I am aware of them. I don't think those add very much
for me. situation to be stuck in >> we'll keep looking.
>> because I mean, streaming is my hobby
and my job. Like, it's a huge part of my life even before, you
know, I met him and became like a larger creator.
I would say the one thing that maybe gets colored a little bit
is in the filing it says that it's the one of the worst events
in Emiru's entire life. I do think the fact that they got put
back together seems to suggest that it's probably not one of
the worst events ever, but I it doesn't mean she wasn't insulted.
People people look like I like I said when we first brought it
up women go back to guys who like break their nose, who break
their jaws, who break their orbital sockets, like their orbital
bones. Like women go back to abusive pieces of [__]
all the time. The fact that she was still talking to him or they
went back to dating doesn't necessarily mean anything.
Right? If they if they talked about it
it'd be different, right?
And I remember
thinking all the time how it felt like he hated me, but he still
wanted me around for his channel and like his thumbnails and
everything, bro. He was using her for content.
Dog, it's an evil world out here, man. You think he like you?
Nah, you good for clicks and views. Yep.
It happens. These statements are nearly identical to the daughter's
statements in the Bensing trade.
I don't think that's the case.
I think
I don't think you get emotional the way Miz did or like Emiru
did based on like the whole thing. They both said it was toxic.
I don't think it gets like that if it's just about like content
or something to be honest with you. Or it gets like that in a
one-sided way. Doesn't get that like that on both >> is
Emiru expressing her heartfelt emotional journey over several
years with an admittedly toxic man.
There go that man thing again. Her story is admirable.
And in telling it she is stating her emotional truth not some
statement of decisive fact.
Oof. So is this is she walking back the essay claims?
She's like, "Oh, no, that's not That's my emotional truth."
You know, that's not a statement of
It's my emotional truth.
Bro, the damage is done, dog. Emotional truth, statement of fact,
this is game over on Mizkif.
Rip her case? Um No, I don't think it's over yet.
I don't think it's over yet.
I think it's going to come down to like what a reasonable person
could interpret as interpret as assault. And I do think that
a reasonable person could interpret those events as assault.
I just don't It's like Again, I'll just I'll explain. There's
this split between the two parties. One party sees it one way.
It's Mizkif. He sees somebody he's like had sex with multiple
times. He's gone through the same escalation pattern multiple
times. He's thinking, "Oh, we're getting back together. It's
like makeup sex. That's why I'm here. That's why she invited
me over so we can have makeup sex." And then she was crying a
little bit, but it was like maybe that had already happened.
I have no [__] idea exactly what happened, okay?
But then he's going to escalate and she freaks out. And he jumps
back and then he's like, "Fuck." And then he leaves,
As soon as he became aware that it was that it was bad, that
it wasn't okay, he
From his point of view, he was going through the normal motions
with her, something he'd done hundreds of times or hopefully
at least dozens of times for his sake before, okay?
And he
he it it [__] it was [__] up and then
he left. For her, like I get it, she was not feeling like it
was a sexual thing. She was kind of like maybe she might have
felt uncomfortable when she first got kissed and then it went
to something sexual, too, and and she felt like it was like a
Entirely possible for these two people The whole point of charging
with somebody with assault is like they are sort of like ruthlessly
disregarding somebody's consent or like willfully like negligently
regarding somebody's consent. I think he falls slightly below
the negligence part. Like I don't think he quite meets that bar.
He obviously doesn't meet the maliciousness part.
But that's my That's my subjective take. I I think both can have
a totally different interpretation of the same
And both not be like evil people who have tried to destroy the
other person.
I don't think that's crazy. I think there's like actually a lot
of cases like this in terms of There There are a lot of cases
like this. That are exactly like this.
Unfortunately, I do think
you would like this not to go if it is some case like that. It's
like
If Amy brought this by herself entirely, I maybe wouldn't really
judge her for it. It depends on how much those other two got
involved. They're talking about like the nuke, oh we're going
to get this guy. We're going to get this guy. We're going to
get this guy.
Just watch what happens, Miss Kiff. Watch. We got something for
you, buddy. We got something for you. And they're clearly referring
to this the whole time. If they're like amping her up behind
the scenes, it's kind of [__] up that this became
public, to be honest with you. Interestingly, that Benson case
also directly dealt with the question of whether accusing someone
of SA constitutes defamation.
There, the daughter used the term SA without explaining exactly
what occurred between her and the stepfather.
Unlike the first amended complaint, there the court had to benefit
of the daughter's entire statement to review.
The argument of that, the court held because the Texas Penal
Code defines criminal offenses as SA,
and Guerrero published a statement that Chris had SA'd her without
further explanation,
the words Guerrero used were reasonably capable of a defamatory
meaning, an example that Chris had committed a criminal offense
of SA against her. For purposes of the TCPA,
this was sufficient for the father's claims to survive the initial
challenge by the
Okay, so I'm guessing because Emiru describes the events instead
of just the the accusation,
that it won't survive in the same way, right? What?
As we continue,
Mizkif will certainly focus on Emiru's use of the term essay,
which she should. I mean, I would do the same. And argue that
Emiru's statements are necessarily defamatory
because they include the same term.
However, in comparison to Benson here,
Emiru described in detail the exact A A lawyer should know that
this is the [__] this is prop logic. And I I'm too
tired to actually figure out what the term is, but it's like
just because you know that if you only use the term, that was
something that survives,
it doesn't mean that Sorry, if you only use the term, don't describe
the events, that the claim survives or the What are you the It
survives like some challenge. It doesn't mean that if you do
describe the events, that like it's you can suddenly get something
dismissed. That's not what that means. Like that you can't use
this precedent where they where the person didn't describe the
events. She just said sexual assault. So then that could reasonably
be defamatory. You can't say just because she described the events
that it can't be defamatory.
That's just not true. It obviously could be her description of
events and still be defamatory, especially if she's like leaving
things out. Right? That nature of Mizkif's That's why that's
why I would say the assault claim from earlier, basically, especially
when they're so disconnected in the live stream,
I would say that's what
That's what makes it hard for me to let that just go. >> assault
against her. Bizarrely, this is the one sentence that Mizkif
actually quotes in the first amended complaint. He started kissing
me in the face. I let him do it.
it's something along these There is like a prop logic thing that's
happening here and it's it is like this. Yes. >> And then
he suddenly tried to climb on top of me and aggressively shoved
his hands down my pants. I screamed and when I screamed he jumped
off me like a cat.
Taking the whole context
Oh, man.
I was on Emaru's side. I feel like you should go grab my vod.
You should go grab my vod and and cite it in this case. Where
I'm like watching it and I'm like, well, even with her description
I don't necessarily know if that's
Show that some very reasonable fellow didn't believe this was
assault from moment one. takes Emaru's statement into account
as the court or is required to do, the situation is very different
than the stepfather in Benson. Emaru describes exactly what happened
to her and although she defines it as SA, a reasonable viewer
would unquestionably
understand that the term is her own description of what happened
to her. I don't know about this. This is a reach. If someone
says comes out and say I was SA and then like later down the
line say he kissed me and finger popped me and then I yelled
and he got off me. Hey, yo! Hey, yo! Are you good, dog? The It's
a assault case.
You talk about finger popping. What the
What the hell?
Bruh. Okay. All right, that caught me really off guard.
I don't know. I don't know, maybe.
It's It's still the term SA.
The viewer is not left to guess as to the nature of the assault
based on solely on the term SA like in Benson's case which
how many people
only saw that one the the disconnect in the stream also matters,
right? So, she says that part about assault. So, that is what?
20 minutes in assault, but then
um shoved.
It's 30 minutes later in the stream when the the story actually
comes out. I would say it's kind of rough that you only did So,
you did the assault part and then it's 30 minutes later where
you do the aggressively shoved. Even if even if this was more
muddy and she like made it clear that she just felt it was an
opinion or something. Even if it was more money muddy, I don't
think you would um
I don't think you get away with this. I think it would still
be a problem. And I want you guys to know that um Melissa has
been making sure that, you know, me and my roommates who are
obviously other uh pretty well-known girl streamers
Assuming you want to argue that it was just your emotional feeling,
you don't necessarily like stand on it.
I've I'm like up two minds here. Cuz the I don't like the argument
the lawyer's making, but the the lawyer's just making really
bad arguments. I think the argument of yeah, this happened to
me. I felt like I was assaulted. I felt like I was violated.
I think this is assault.
If that's all you're saying
and like these events are something a reasonable person could
interpret as assault, I think she probably is okay
I don't know that I don't know that legally proving it would
come into play.
Because of the It's like it's actually really rough because if
you said somebody I would not have this opinion if you said somebody
robbed you.
They stole money from me. Somebody like embezzled money from
my company. And then you're like, well, it was just an emotional
thing. Like there's not really an emotional weight to that and
it's not a a crime that's incredibly difficult to prove. Like
the it's the fact that it's assault that makes it so difficult
to try to hold her to try to hold her liable for defamation.
Man, that's rough. That's That's a tough one. All the things
that makes assault hard to prove
make it hard for me to say you have to prove it beyond a reasonable
doubt or even to a, you know, preponderance of evidence to make
the accusation to say it publicly.
And I would imagine there's actually probably
arguments about this. I'm guessing this would around the Me Too
Like why didn't all these women just get accused of of defamation
during the Me Too stuff, right?
Am I crazy?
Why wouldn't like every single Me Too story just be defamation?
They're like all years after the fact.
You can just call people rapists for
especially when the events aren't like heavily disputed, when
it's like acknowledged that the events kind of did happen in
some way.
Ah, it's it's rough, man.
It is rough, actually.
I don't know.
That we have been safe here paying for like security stuff, making
sure we're protected. Again, my my manager has been taking care
of all of her own. Twitch did not offer anything like that. Oh,
um how did I click on this? My bad. My bad, I'm closing this.
focused on the fact that the daughter did not actually describe
the alleged assault.
I think this would become defamation
if these events didn't happen.
But unfortunately for Miz, I do think these events happened in
roughly the way she described. Maybe like maybe she's being a
little more brutal with the details, but the details are something
that I do think go to like an emotional fact. That she might
not have written the details down perfectly or it's understandable
that you would be emotional writing those details down in like
in a obvious sense. What's the second video? We're going to watch
the second video at some point here. Amour's difficult defense
in Miz lawsuit case. We are going to watch this one.
Okay, it might not fly. >> Required viewing. The judge
will determine it.
Just like in Benson, Amour's statements are not actionable as
defamation because they show her personal viewpoint, her own
emotional truth in Well, the issue is King of Whim in defamation
per se, I think you basically So, either you need to show like
intentional malice or if you want to go defamation per se, you're
accusing them of a crime. You can
basically it's like you're accusing them of a crime. You have
to have You have to believe they committed the crime and I think
believe I think in some cases you have to prove they did the
crime. Like it's basically saying
that you can't accuse them of like robbing a bank if you have
no evidence they robbed a bank if you if they haven't robbed
a bank basically.
Per se only affects damages. Okay. Well, I thought I thought
actual malice didn't wasn't required for per se. That like the
ma the actual malice is in accusing them of the crime without
like without basically even being able to prove it all that they
did it.
Maybe I'm mis- Maybe I'm
I think my understanding of defamation per se comes from Dan
telling me what defamation per se was on a stream once. So, almost
certainly it's been >> and not purported fact. The court
should dismiss the first amended complaint as to Mizkif.
Man, that emotional truth thing is z- bish. But at the same time,
this is federal court. Federal court. TCPA don't
So, you have that element.
Amour's claim was emotional might not fly because she prefaced
the whole thing by describing it as essay.
That really couldn't be described as anything as a statement
of fact.
We're going to find out. The mini complaint must be dismissed
as to Mizkif enterprises because the first amended complaint
absolutely no allegations or statements by Imaru regarding to
the enterprises. I agree with this. Get Miskif Enterprises off
the defamation thing.
Count two of the amended complaint, which is syntactically, scantily,
and sloppily played, contains absolutely no allegations pertaining
to the defamation
by Imaru of Miskif Enterprises. I agree with that. Let's keep
going. The only reference uh to the court into which include
Miskif Enterprises are the plaintiffs collectively.
Plaintiffs incorporate the prior >> I don't know how much
more of this video we need. I think we're basically all the way
to the end of what we need out of this video. Okay?